.
>> MINUS TEN.
GO FOR LAUNCH.
AND WE ARE --
AND WE'RE CLEAR OF THE --
>> THE VEHICLE IS SUPERSONIC.
>> THE CALL THERE INDICATING,
FASTER THAN THE SPEED OF SOUND.
>> MAX Q.
NEXT ONE THROTTLE ON.
>> NOW THAT WERE PASSED MAX Q
--
>> COPY, ONE BRAVO.
>> THAT ONE BRAVO INDICATOR AND
DIFFERENT ABORT MODES THAT ARE
CALLED AND ALLOW THE GROUND
TEAMS AND THE CREW TO TRACK
ABOUT POSITION OF THE BALCONY
AND IN THE DRAGON AS THEY MAKE
THEIR WAY UP THE EASTERN
SEABOARD IN THE EVENT OF AN
ABORT, THE POSITION WHERE
DRAGON WOULD --
AS WELL AS INDICATE WHAT SERIES
OF MANEUVERS DRAGON WOULD
INDICATE.
BUT SO FAR WE ARE HEARING GOOD
CALLS ON THE PERFORMANCE OF
FALCON 9 ON ITS RIDE UPHILL.
ONE MINUTE 53 SECONDS
IN-FLIGHT.
>> WE'RE ABOUT 30 SECONDS AWAY
FROM MAIN ENGINE CUTOFF, WHICH
WILL BE FOLLOWED QUICKLY BY
STAGE SEPARATION AND SECOND
ENGINE START, WHICH IS THE
IGNITION OF THAT BACK ENGINE ON
THE SECOND STAGE.
>> NOW ABOUT TEN SECONDS AWAY
FROM MAIN ENGINE CUTOFF.
>> AND THERE WE HAVE IT, A
SPECTACULAR NIGHTTIME LAUNCH.
IT'S AMAZING HOW, NO MATTER HOW
MANY TIMES YOU SEE IT, IT TAKES
YOUR BREATH AWAY WHEN THESE
LAUNCHES TAKE PLACE.
>> OH YES, VERY SPECTACULAR 90
PLANTERS, VERY DIFFERENT FROM A
DAY LAUNCH.
YOU CAN SEE THE VEHICLE FOR A
LOT LONGER BECAUSE YOU CAN SEE
THE ENGINES BURNING, SO VERY
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE, AND HERE
WE HAVE SEEN THE FIRST STAGE IS
SEPARATED SUCCESSFULLY, SECOND
STAGE IGNITED, AND SO
EVERYTHING IS LOOKING GREAT SO
FAR.
>> AND LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT
THE VEHICLE THAT'S GETTING IN
--
THE.
THE FALCON 9 ROCKET TOPPED BY
AN ATOMIC AUTONOMY'S THEY'RE
ORGANIZED CREW.
>> ESPECIALLY DURING THE LAUNCH
PHASE THEY ARE IN AUTOMATIC
MODE.
THEY ARE MONITORING ALL THE
SYSTEMS AND THERE'S ACTUALLY
VERY LITTLE CONTROL THE CREW
HAS RIGHT NOW.
IF THEY HAD TO ABORT, IF
SOMETHING WENT WRONG IN THE
HEAD SEPARATING COME BACK, THEY
COULD INITIATE THAT MANUALLY.
IT COULD ALSO BE INITIATED
AUTOMATICALLY IN CASE OF A
SENSOR THAT DETECTS THE
ANOMALY.
BUT RIGHT NOW THEY'RE JUST
MONITORING ALL THE SYSTEMS AND
MAKING SURE EVERYTHING IS FINE
AND SO FAR IT LOOKS LIKE
EVERYTHING IS RIGHT ON THE
MONEY.
>> AND THESE GUYS WILL BE AT
THE INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION
WHEN THE BOEING CREW FLIGHT
TEST ARRIVES.
THAT'S GOING TO BE IN APRIL.
THIS IS THE FIRST, WHAT, THE
LAST UP ON BOWING TO GET THEIR
--
FOR SPACE TRAVEL?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, SO THIS
OBTAINING SCHEDULE MISSION FOR
THE STARLINER IS THE FIRST TO
CARRY ASTRONAUTS.
SO THIS IS A BIG ONE FOR
BOEING.
AND SO STARLINER, IF EVERYTHING
GOES, WELL WE'LL DARK AT THE
STATION IN APRIL AND THAT WILL
BE ANOTHER BIG MILESTONE.
>> IN THE MEANTIME, WHILE
THEY'RE WAITING FOR THE
STARLINER MISSION, THESE GUYS
WILL CARRY ABOUT 200 FALCONS
EXPERIENCE OR UP?
THERE THEY WE'D HEAR ABOUT
THESE EXPERIMENTS ALL THE TIME,
BUT ARE THEY JUST BUSY WORK?
>> NO, THESE ARE DEFINITELY OF
HIGH VALUE.
WE CONCENTRATE MOSTLY ON LIFE
SCIENCE EXPERIMENTS, BECAUSE IT
TURNS OUT THAT BEING IN THE
SPACE ENVIRONMENT FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME IS ACTUALLY
PRETTY CHALLENGING FOR THE
HUMAN BODY, PRETTY CHALLENGING
FOR HEALTH, AND SO WE DO THESE
DIFFERENT BIOMEDICAL
EXPERIMENTS TO HELP VALIDATE
AND DEVELOP THESE BIO MEDICAL
COUNTERMEASURES WHICH WE HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT BEFORE WE START
SENDING CREWS TO PLACES LIKE
MEYER SO THEY WILL BE DOING
MOSTLY BIOMEDICAL EXPERIENCE
BUT GOOD ALSO EXPECTANCY
MATERIAL SCIENCE EXPERIENCE AND
SOME OTHER FUNDAMENTAL PHYSICS
EXPERIMENTS.
SO THEY'LL BE DOING A WHOLE
GAMUT OF DIFFERENT KINDS OF
RESEAR